buenas noches tengo una confesión
es algo que he ocultado toda mi vida
pero siento que es el momento de
liberarme
por muchos años había estado apenado
pero el día de hoy quiero compartirlo
con ustedes
lo que quiero decirles
es que me encantan las matemáticas
porque es una confesión porque siempre
viví creyendo que era malo que me
gustaban las matemáticas no estaba bien
visto por ejemplo una vez me invitaron
en la escuela a representar a la escuela
en un concurso nacional de matemáticas y
decidí no ir porque sabía que divide a
social estado en riesgo y toda la vida
viví pensando que tenía que esconder mi
gusto por las matemáticas cuando en
realidad para mirar muy importantes y el
día de hoy les quiero compartir un poco
de por qué son tan importantes para mí
las matemáticas
hay un concepto de las matemáticas que
me encanta que es el punto de inflexión
pero que es el punto de inflexión
imaginemos esta línea esta línea solo
sabemos que es una línea creciente que
va aumentando pero no sabemos más podría
ser que esta línea en realidad si vemos
un poco más de información va creciendo
y luego se va a estancar o tal vez
podría hacer que esa línea es una
recuperación que venía bajando y ahora
llego al nivel inicial o tal vez podría
hacer que esta línea llego un máximo y
ahora va a caer en picada y ese punto en
el que cambia la dirección de la línea
es el punto de inflexión para mí ese
punto es muy importante porque nos dice
mucho más información de lo que está
pasando pero sobre todo el punto de
inflexión nos cuenta historias el día de
hoy decidió contar tres historias tres
puntos de inflexión que han transformado
la historia de mi vida
el primer punto de inflexión tiene que
ver con mi trabajo actual
desde el primer día y hasta el día de
hoy ha sido mi trabajo soñado trabajo en
el sector social ayuda a la educación de
mi país y además trabajo para fundación
luego una marca de la que he sido
fanático toda la vida
digo que es un punto de inflexión porque
aprendido sobre la importancia del juego
hoy estoy convencido de que el juego es
fundamental para que niños y niñas
aprendan y se desarrollen plenamente
por ejemplo siempre me ha llamado mucho
la atención como mi sobrina desde los 2
años le gustaba mucho el juego de rol
este juego en el que pretende ser
alguien más pretende ser una maestra
pretende ser una doctora y cuando está
haciendo eso está desarrollando muchas
habilidades está aprendiendo a crear
escenarios a imaginar posibilidades en
el futuro cuando mi sobrina se enfrente
a situaciones adversas le va a ser de
mucha utilidad esta capacidad de
imaginar que hay otras posibilidades que
otras opciones en la vida o pensemos en
un niño de 3 años que le cuesta mucho
trabajo concentrarse cuando se enfoque
en este tipo de juego está tan metido en
su personaje que no permite
distracciones porque tiene que seguir el
juego lo que está desarrollando este
niño es autocontrol y es fundamental
cuando los niños chicos desarrollan
autocontrol cuando son adultos son
personas más saludables y personas con
mejor control financiero estos son sólo
dos ejemplos de cómo el aprendizaje a
través del juego puede ser importante
para cambiar la vida de niños y niñas el
segundo punto de inflexión pasó hace dos
años cuando fue la crisis de refugiados
con una amiga estábamos viendo y nos
sentíamos impotentes todo lo que
podíamos hacer era ver las noticias y
compartir historias en redes sociales
así es que decidimos tomar acción
tomamos un avión y fuimos a atenas a un
campo de refugiados para ver cómo
podríamos ayudar a esta emergencia
nunca voy a olvidar el día que llegamos
a ese campo
en uno de los puertos principales es un
estacionamiento muy grande
había alrededor de 5000 familias que
habían perdido todo
cinco mil familias que todo lo que
tenían era la ropa que estaban usando y
una tienda de campaña
llegamos viendo cómo podíamos ayudar y
lo primero que nos dijeron fue que el
enfoque había sido en ayudar en las
necesidades básicas entonces se habían
preocupado del techo de la ropa de la
comida pero nadie había hecho nada por
los niños y nos pidieron que hiciéramos
algo al respecto
y para mí el momento ideal porque yo
llevo un año en mi trabajo ya sabía todo
de la importancia del juego sabía que
una herramienta muy importante para
niños estaba en esta situación así es
que fuimos juntamos a un grupo de niños
yo saque materiales actividades y yo
estaba listo para cambiarles la vida
para no ser la historia larga fue un
fracaso
fue un fracaso porque yo no había
entendido que lo último que querían
estos niños era estructura y seguir
instrucciones y no había entendido todo
lo que habían vivido y que cada
situación requiere un tipo de juego
diferente nos dimos cuenta que no había
funcionado pero vemos que en el fondo
había un juego de fútbol
en el lugar que ven en la foto estaba
pasando un juego llevamos a los vídeos
que habíamos juntado y empezó el juego
sin mucha estructura éramos a román por
30 personas niños de entre 6 y 18 años
niños niñas a veces hacíamos para un
lado a veces para el otro a veces éramos
20 contra 10 15 contra 15
eran niños de afganistán de eritrea de
siria
no lo en el mismo idioma entonces no se
podían comunicar entre ellos
pero todo el juego empezó a surgir
orgánicamente porque todos sabíamos cuál
era el objetivo del juego y ahí llegó mi
segundo punto de inflexión pasar de la
teoría a la práctica me di cuenta que a
través del juego los niños se estaban
comunicando estaban socializando y por
un instante se estaban olvidando de todo
lo que habían vivido y estaban
disfrutando este momento
el tercer punto de inflexión tiene que
ver con esta plática cuando empecé a
preparar la tuve que reflexionar mucho
sobre mi vida
y en esta reflexión me di cuenta que el
juego siempre ha estado presente en mi
vida y que ha sido una parte fundamental
en esta reflexión recordé cuando yo
tenía siete años
me llamaría una tienda de ropa me
gustaba mucho ir a la tienda en el
verano y todos los días
usaba la calculadora me gustaba jugar me
gustaba hacer las cuentas y me gustaba
cerrar los inventarios con mi llama lo
hacía todos los días lo disfrutaba mucho
pero el momento que se volvió muy
tedioso porque siempre era lo mismo
y así a mis 9 años decidí que era
momento de emprender tuve mi primer
negocio a mis nueve años
empecé la venta de conejos mis papás me
llevaban al mercado de sonora compré
seis conejos machos y hembras los
llevamos a una casa de campo que tenía
en hidalgo
y lo primero que hicimos va a ser una
jaula para separar los machos de las
hembras yo pensé que la explicación que
me habían dado era suficiente para saber
cómo distinguir un macho de una hembra
no lo fue
dos meses después en lugar de seis
conejos tenía setenta
mi modelo de negocio cambió
considerablemente mis costos juegan
hacia arriba así es que tuve que
trabajar en las ventas salí a las calles
de la ciudad de mexico a vender conejos
como mascotas
y tuve mi primer aprendizaje como
emprendedor la gente no quiere conejos
como mascotas
pero también aprendí que había un
negocio que podría hacer más redituable
la venta de borregos
los borregos requerían menos manutención
no se reproducían como conejos
y yo no sentía culpa de venderlos para
barbacoa y seis meses después duplicaron
su valor no requerir mucha inversión y
forme un negocio muy redituable
para mí esas actividades serán solo un
juego pero en realidad yo estaba
siguiendo mi interés por los números que
tanto me apenaba ni que escondía a
través del juego y también me di cuenta
que el rol de mis tropas fue fundamental
el rol de los adultos que facilitaron el
juego cuando me llevaron al mercado
cuando me dejaban usar la calculadora
ellos me permitieron escoger cuál es el
juego que yo quería y ellos pusieron
todas las condiciones para que sepa que
funcionaria
y por qué les digo todo esto porque los
últimos tres años
yo he recorrido muchos partes de méxico
y tengo la fortuna de estar en muchas
partes del mundo y ha sido testigo de
cómo el juego transforma la vida de
niños y niñas y por eso yo quiero
pedirles
que no dejen de jugar pero sobre todo
que no olvidemos el rol que tenemos como
adultos de facilitar el juego que así
como el juego me ayudó a seguir mis
intereses que ustedes a facilitar el
juego puedan ayudar a niños y niñas a
seguir y cumplir sus sueños muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]